a vigil will be held today for the  student athlete from Desert Oasis High  School who died last week after  collapsing on the field sixteen-year-old  ashara Hughes was playing flag football  when she had a medical emergency her  staff did what they could to save her  until paramedics arrived unfortunately  they were unable to do so tonight  there'll be a vigil at Centennial High  School on the football field it begins  at 4 30. the Hughes family has set up a  GoFundMe if you'd like to help them some  good news to share they've met their  goal of fifty thousand dollars hitting  more than fifty three thousand dollars  but if you'd still like to donate and  help out that family we have information  on how you can do that on our website we  also have a complete list of events  honoring ashara Hughes go to  8newsnow.com